There is so much confusion
children, we remove this confusion,
I am going to tell you the check list which
you should carry in the exam, first
test is
blue color pen, do not use black, it will remain butter, don't forget to carry your
admit card,
character is very important to give the exam.  You will not
get it
after that. Watch it is very important
for time management. Fourth point is water bottle. Don't
forget a water bottle. Then fifth
point will be ours that we have to take you to the
writing post so that you know it well and you
can write clearly. And the last point is this.
Please don't forget you carry your school ID
sometimes you are asked right so that's all
gas all the best